japan got an early christmas present
this year a toy that
won't exactly fit under the tree a giant
walking gesturing warrior robot is now
on display in the port city
of yokohama half an hour south of tokyo
lucy kraft got a close-up look at this
high-tech wonder
it's all systems go as japan's mighty
warrior
struts its stuff twists its mighty torso
and lifts gigantic arms heavenward
before appearing to blast off into outer
space
guarding japan's port city of yokohama
is the newly unveiled fighting robot
known as gondom
to get a good close look of the robot's
head we've had to take an elevator up to
the sixth floor
this is one shiny new toy that won't fit
under the christmas tree
six years in the making the life-sized
robot celebrates a 40 year old anime
sci-fi sensation
often compared to star wars or star trek
because of its devoted fan base
out of this world cultural impact gundam
is one of the most lucrative media
franchises on earth
its figurines plastic model kits and
even robot embossed snacks
helping rake in tens of billions of
dollars
without its massive supporting gantry
the nearly 60-foot
25-ton colossus of steel and
fiber-reinforced plastic
would topple right over it looks like a
robot
but inside it's just a big mechanical
system said technical director akinori
ishii
the challenge was making it look like a
gondom that means giving the humanoid as
many joints as possible
for a life-like range of motion built to
withstand even earthquakes and typhoons
gondom has its marching orders to keep
flexing its joints for audiences
until 2022 for cbs this morning saturday
lucy craft yokohama japan lucy has like
the best
good stuff right but that's not a
transformer no it's gondom
okay yeah yeah predates the
transformation kind of a transfer okay
thank you